Oh, America is this, in Europe it's this,...
...then we should be like this.
Why do we have to become like other countries?
That's actually a good point.
If Japan wants to change,...
...it shouldn't be just because Japan is not like the West.
I personally don't get this kind of argument...
...because just getting closer to the West...
...doesn't mean women in Japan become happier.
Having said that, of course, it does not mean either;...
...Japan doesn't need to change anything.
So, what do we need to change?
One of the most important things...
...is having females in leadership positions.
People in the senior leadership positions...
...regardless of whether you're running a country...
...or whether you're running an organization,...
...that group gets to make the policies or rules or laws of that country...
...or the organization, right?
And that affects everyone under them.
If those policies are made by just one type of group, just men,...
...those rules and policies are designed to fit men.
I think it's super important to have diverse perspectives at the leadership level...
...so that whatever the policies that they try to design, are more inclusive.